What’s the difference between a migrant
and refugee?
“Migrant” is an umbrella term for asylum
seekers, refugees, and economic migrants.
Asylum seekers are people fleeing persecution
or conflict.
Once an asylum claim is approved, the asylum
seeker becomes a refugee.
The UN will sometimes give people from countries
like Syria blanket refugee status.
Refugees are entitled to rights and protections spelled
out in international treaties.
Economic migrants are people who leave home
to look for work.
They are not entitled to the same protections
as refugees under international law.
In reality, these two groups can and often
overlap.
Many people fleeing conflict are often looking
to escape poverty, too.
This is an important distinction to make when
responding to crises.
Like those unfolding around the world today.